hey guys Ryan right here so today we're
checking out a movie clip for a film I
want to see but honestly I saw the third
one last night and I was like ah maybe
I'm not so excited for some reason it
got me not as excited Terminator Genisys
movie clip the t1000 attack this movie
already has a lot of spoilers and the
trailers and stuff but sure let's watch
another spoiler yeah let's let's watch a
scene that probably would have been cool
to wait for the theaters but everyone's
asking us to watch it
tell me if you want to live now soldier
that was so short no hmm-hmm-hmm
there are things I can gather from this
clip though okay cinematography looks
good yes I like the cinematography of
what I've seen thus far
there's something about Jai Courtney
that I just don't like I don't know what
I was thinking about last night actually
I just I don't know something makes me
feel like he's a douchebag in real life
which makes me not like him I don't know
I've seen Jai Courtney in several films
boys like I don't know something about
you man it's not fair there's divergent
a good day to die hard first thing I saw
him it was Jack Reacher this is Michael
Biehn was such like a unique type of
presents for Kyle Reese and I don't feel
like Jai Courtney will bring that you
know some people are saying like oh this
is not a sequel you know it's a reboot
in total I'm like it's kind of a sequel
come on
the whole point is they're going back
and to the past of the first Terminator
and then things are changing so that
wouldn't make any sense to us if we did
not see the first Terminator so you know
so it has to be a sequel in some fashion
actually I think it would make sense if
we hadn't seen the previous ones if
we're just a completely new generation
of audience no I'm sure it'll make sense
in some way like but for someone to say
that it has nothing to do with the
originals I think that's just such it's
total [ __ ] well the Kerr [ __ ]
the characters are obviously borrowed
from yeah
who's the girl Emilia Clarke Emilia
Clarke she's diners in game of Danny
baronies when I saw the footage of the
trailer when she was like come with me
if you want to live I was like I don't
know if I go by this chick but watching
the clip and like seeing the whole
sequence play out I was like yeah okay I
believed her this time around I think
the t1000 looks really awesome and I
really still believe it he just looks
all exactly the same as the original
t1000 really I'm distracted by the fact
that he looks really Asian cuz I just
saw it's from Reiter - a few days ago
yeah then I see this
like this looks like a total Asian
version of but doesn't mean look the
same oh you're wrong I think he looks
the same I just can't get over the fact
that's something that I'm mentioned
previously when I saw this yeah well
good I still think he likes the same and
I love how they paint like a really nice
homage to the old one like they still
use his my fans that's a good way to put
it didn't I pan and he like scrapes
across the floor and then when he tries
to kill him with his yeah what I like
about what I'm seeing from the clips of
terminator genisys and the trailers is
they're taking like a lot of it's like
your greatest hits of like a bunch of
different sequences of the terminators
and sort of throwing it into this one
world now and it's been so long since
I've seen of it so I can't say well the
first ones great second one is so good
the third one was letdown and the fourth
one I think we can all forget about that
well anyway guys thanks for tuning in to
the reject channel you can subscribe to
the real rejects you can check out
Brandy's shadow
trying to be a youtuber and promote
people with energy you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter where if
we get enough followers we can get
product listen for things such as porta
viar-toe porta viar-toe is a great place
it is filled with all kinds of Mexican
prostitutes that have been thrown into
the slave trade don't worry they're not
underage their nerd ult's okay so the
slave trades okay I'm hoping to get
sponsorship from them because my dream
yeah I wouldn't mind you know sponsoring
like the Port of IR - slave trade way
cuz you think you're gonna get some from
it while I make money off of it or
obsession abou they probably had
diseases well those are pregnant - yeah
you're right
porta viar-toe